the world is experiencing Karuna virus
pandemic the worst pandemic in last 100
years it started in one China from there
it has spread to Italy and throughout
200 countries in the whole world in this
situation we need to understand how to
fight back against this virus remember
in this case our enemy is invisible so
let's see and let's try to know how we
can fight back
how hand-washing can help so let's say
this individual is infected with corona
virus now when he coughs or sneeze he is
putting his droplets filled up with
corona virus in the air studies have
shown that corona virus can persist in
air for at least 3 to 4 hours and on
surfaces it can stay for even days now
let's say another individual that's the
same surface on which that previous
individual has sneezed or coughed now
the droplets comes to his hand and next
time when he touches his hand - anywhere
he is infecting the other people as well
for example hand shaking or while
returning home he is going to the
supermarket he is touching the
supermarket cart and putting the virus
there as well while taking out money
let's say he is transmitting the virus
or putting the virus in that surface and
the virus can stay on that surface for
long now while another individual touch
that same cart not knowing that there is
virus the virus goes to his arms as well
and next time he touches his face with
the hand the game is over we can
understand the degree of transmission of
this virus and how dangerous it is none
of these things we actively perceive
while doing our everyday work right but
it's the time to perceive these kind of
things that what
the possible ways that you can get
exposed to the virus from exchanging
money exchanging plastic goods or taking
groceries packets these things can
really transmit the virus right at this
situation what is doable or what is
recommended by WH o is washing hands
let's say the man is not washed the man
has not washed his hand and taking an
elevator in the elevator door in the
door handle of his home he is spreading
the virus and keeping it on the surface
and before the virus can die out it
takes several days for the virus to die
out right so the virus would be
transmitted to another individual who
whosoever touched the door handle or
touch the elevator door so that is why
it's time to fight back in this
situation the first thing we should do
after coming back to home from outside
is to take a soap I the liquid soap or
soap bar and then repeatedly wash the
hands and the six steps of hand-washing
is shown by WH o so wash our hands
thoroughly for at least thirty to forty
seconds now let's talk about what is the
mechanism of the killing of the virus so
it is very similar the way we remove oil
stain from our clothes so in order to
remove oil stain we put liquid detergent
in the washing machine and what happens
is the oil stains are removed by the
surfactants so the detergent molecules
are also polar in nature so detergent
molecules literally pull out the dirt
from the surface and put them nicely
around it similar things happens in case
of Karuna virus so Karuna virus is an
enveloped RNA virus envelope simply
means it has a lipid coat the lipid coat
is very much similar to the oil droplets
that extends our clothes as well now in
order to remove the lipid droplet you
can use soap
or detergent now soap molecules are very
similar to the lipid molecules because
soap molecules also have hydrophobic
hydrophobic tail and hydrophilic head
group hydrophilic means it is water
loving and hydrophobic means it is water
hating now this is the virus and when
you wash your hands with soap water what
happens is the hydrophobic tails are
interacting with the hydrophobic tails
of the phospholipid present in the viral
envelope and they are pretty happy with
each other because they are interacting
with hydrophobic interaction now some of
these drop some of these soap my series
take out phospholipids from the virus
membrane and damage the virus envelope
now you can understand while using soap
and water for a long time the viral
envelope can be severely damaged a
damaged virus is not so efficient in
terms of infecting so its virulence
factor would be reduced but this
phenomena is only possible when you wash
your hands thoroughly for at least 20 to
30 seconds below that the cleansing
mechanism won't be efficient the
exchanging of these phospholipids and
moving that into them soap my series
won't be sufficient enough so it's
necessary that you wash your hand for at
least 20 to 30 seconds beyond that is
even better but that's the minimum
threshold now it is also true that these
viruses are RNA viruses so if we dip our
clothes or the things that we think that
that would be exposed to virus like our
clothes while coming out from well
coming back from outside we need to dip
it in boiling water at least the
temperature should be 60 degrees and
above based is boiling water which would
be 100 degrees we
at that temperature the proteins or the
spikes that are present on the outer
surface of the virus would be denatured
so as the genetic material which is RNA
it won't be stable at that high
temperature unfortunately we cannot be
power hand in that boiling water because
it would cause bond that's why
repeatedly hand-washing with soap would
be very efficient in this situation do
you want to know how hand sanitizers
work then stay tuned to my channel and
subscribe my channel because I would be
posting a lot of updates about corona
virus and telling you the science and
facts about it and bust all the myths
but also keep an eye on the news
channels and at this situation we cannot
prevent it but we can know our enemy
such that we can avoid our enemy in this
situation stay safe if you liked this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe
please share this video to grow our and
s and educate people education is the
thing that we need education and
awareness can really help us to cope up
with this situation and try to stay I
mean try to bring safety to our family
and our in our friends thank you